- Yellowstone was so huge.
It's such a huge show, right?
Like, how, were you,
were y'all both nervous
about stepping into the prequel thing
or were you excited because there were,
there's already this huge fan base?
- Gosh, you don't want to go do something
that they're not gonna like, you know.
You have so much respect
for Kevin and the cast
and certainly Taylor,
who wrote 1883 as well.
I mean, you, you wanna,
you wanna, you know,
live up to the, to the expectations
of what everybody expects
out of Yellowstone.
You want 'em to expect
the same thing from 1883,
you wanna live up to it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you certainly want
the cast to like it,
but at the end of the day, you,
you trust the writing,
you trust the directing,
and then you trust your fellow actors
to show up every day on set and deliver.
And I'm telling you,
every actor on this show
and every, and I wanna shout
out to the crew members,
the wranglers, and the stunt guys.
Everybody brought their
A-game every single day.
And these were really tough conditions.
It was a really tough shoot
and everybody just flat brought it.
And I couldn't imagine working
with a better group of people.
- I well, and I honestly,
it was a brilliant play.
Like, what a smart, you know,
play to do a prequel to that.
Like, I was one of those
people that love Yellowstone.
So, 1883 was such a, a brilliant play.
So, I gotta say, you said conditions.
So, I know that y'all filmed
a bit in Texas where I'm from.
Actually, I'm from Fort Worth where y'all,
y'all shot at like the stock yards, right?
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- That was the first place I
ever snuck into a club, hey!
- Woo.
(laughing)
- Only did it once, Mom.
But anyway, it was, it
had to be hot, right?
Where y'all are shooting, and
y'all are layered up, right?
- Oh, a corset and
everything. I felt, yeah.
Sweat poured down parts of my body
I didn't know sweat could
pour down. It was...
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Really. It was rather.
- You haven't gotten
into spanks yet, yeah.
- No, no, I'm not there yet.
(laughing)
Yeah, I'm waiting for that one to come.
But yeah, but you know, I kind
of also enjoyed it somewhat
because I feel like-
- [Kelly] I like the heat.
- Well that, but you also,
you kind of wanna be miserable
because that's exactly what,
- [Kelly] They would've been doing.
- Yeah. Those conditions
were, it was so authentic.
It was so real.
It was so visceral that
I don't think many of us,
when it came to weather
conditions were acting.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- 'Cause we were genuinely
sweating our, our BA.
- [Kelly] Behinds off. No, you
kept it talk-show friendly.
That was nice, yeah.
Way to go you classy
individual. (laughing)